So one of the challenges in
research is how do you pick a topic,
how do you pick a model? I think here
that the key thing is you should ask an
important question. You should ask a
question that a lot of people are
interested in. You should ask a question
that has broad implications.
I think we were lucky, or I should say,
I was lucky, that when I started my
lab, I asked a question that perhaps was
a good question to ask. The question
I asked was: "How do you maintain immunological memory to an infection you got
or a vaccine you got 20 years ago, or 30
years ago or 50 years ago? How is this
memory maintained? So I think the question was a very good one.
But the next stage is how do you
study that question? And the
advice I would give is pick a model
where you can really study the question,
where you can really dissect it,
you can understand it in some detail .
So again, I think made a good choice.
We picked a mouse model. Sometimes people
don't like what you learned from mice
and they - not everything you learn there
extrapolates into humans - but still I
think if you ask the right question,
do it well , those discoveries will hold as
you move up towards human studies.
So we picked a mouse model. And why did we
pick hat particular mouse model?
Because that was a natural -- this virus
that we used which was LCMV is a
natural pathogen of mice.
You can find wild mice in nature
which are infected with this. Of course,
we were not working with those mice,
we were working with mice in the lab,
that infected with LCMV. But the reason I
emphasize that it's a mouse virus
is pathogens evolve with its own host
so if you're studying a mouse virus in a mouse, you really looking at the
interaction between a virus and its
natural host, and this is a much better
than sticking a human virus that doesn't
replicate in mice or replicates poorly.
So if you want to discover fundamentals
of immune responses, do it
with the natural host natural pathogen
and a virus that will replicate
efficiently and give you the all the
things that you need to study in terms
of viral infections. So I think it's
picking the model. And then you ask the
right questions. In this case it was - you
know... I shouldn't say ask the right questions,
should say you should then study what
you want to look at in as much detail as
you can, and again the mouse model allows you to do this. In this particular one,
reagents were available for analyzing
the T-cells, reagents were available to
look at what the virus was contributing,
so it was a well-defined model for
studying immune responses to viral
infection. And then it's interesting how
science moves forward. It depends on how technology is being developed. So our lab
was never developing new technology.
were are immunologists, more I would
say biologists, we are biologists, asking
biological questions, we were
not creating any tools and any reagents.
But others were - the science moves
forward because many people do many
great things. So we were greatly helped
in many different things. I mentioned
to you that we did this gene expression
profiling. Of course we didn't
develop them, but those tools became available.
Tools became available that worked
in other places in terms of looking at
at the appropriate single cell assays
developed to look at expression of
different cytokines. So the techniques
and reagents that developed... One of the
most important reagents that was developed actually was work that John Altman, who's a
faculty member at Emory Vaccine Center,
did when he was at Stanford University,
as a postdoc, and that was the
development of these MHC class 1 tetramers.
These are reagents that you
can use to identify specifically T-cells
reacting against different viruses.
So this development of the tetramer
reagent greatly helped in the analysis that we did.
So my advice there is that
as you ask the right question, pick the model,
and be aware of all the
wonderful technology that's developing
around you, because you have to apply
then the state-of-the-art techniques, no
matter who's developed it. You don't need
to be an expert in it, you just bring the
technique into your lab or you
collaborate with those people
to move it forward.